um when we're talking about harlem
who do you have as your top five harlem
mcs ever
ever ever on big l mace
cam um
uh not me nine take yourself out
um damn
i thought it was more than three from
home i think dave east is making his way
into that kind of no davies is a young
legend that's my god but
he's he's got a catalog though man he's
still young davey's got a lot of catalog
yeah davies is my god davies
yeah davis is definitely he's definitely
up there but
as far as my top five i would say big o
cam mace
do you guys out of respect you put asap
rocky in there just because of the wave
that he created
as far as maybe not lyrically he's not
not liberty
he ain't in there asap rocky is nice
though he's he's
he's a different type of rapper he's a
little bit more creative
when it comes to like putting together
rhymes and songs and it's dope
still but it's not that type of rap the
big big pun
that type of rap that i was influenced
by
like oh caught it yeah but caught in
ain't really like he might not even know
who
they of course i do come on man oh okay
okay
uh bodega babs is fire he i don't need
that's probably not in that conversation
but he's
that's my god he does he definitely
deserves my [ __ ] you know i mean
deserve a shot cause he's nice he's
definitely who else is from harlem or
not we're not thinking of somebody bro
yeah but he just wasn't uh what was the
name his name child of the ghetto
oh that [ __ ] was so fire it was so good
i mean i think i think that one album is
crazy
yeah yeah yeah but he's like he did
catch a body
and find himself you know what's crazy i
was like in poughkeepsie before he
turned himself in
he turned himself in i was in
poughkeepsie performing
and and then i'm on stage rapping and i
see
somebody get on stage with like a big
colorful
bubble coat and i'm like i ain't coming
nobody i could see it from my
from the side of my eye so i look as g
death and he's just like going crazy but
he look a little like
oh so i'm like you know i talked to him
afterwards we we spoke um you was there
for her
yeah i'm just trying to remember it
clear but shout outs to him he was just
that was right before he turned himself
in so i knew it was something a little
bit
a little bit off but shout outs to him
he's still a harlem legend
yeah mace i feel like doesn't also get
enough respect as mc
mace is crazy yeah let's get all the
props in my books
no i just feel like in general we talk
about like based out overall you're
saying yeah
crazy run man crazy run
that double up was a little
disappointing but you know he was trying
to get out that contract that's how i
looked at it he was trying to get away
from it there were some
there was like two records on double up
yeah but i remember buying double up and
i was like oh
damn because he was trying to match it
up with that hauling world
album harlow oh yeah that's right the
harlem world album they came out like
the triple play they came out super that
that's when he was trying he tried to
he dropped double up to get out of his
contract with puff that's what he's
trying to do
and he was like pretty much he said it
like he was kind of forced to put that
guy put together that album whatever
when you were a kid was like when him
and cam and big al
was that like movement like known in in
harlem like
it was children of the corn right yeah
but that was like
i was too young for that yeah yeah i
mean i once i got older i
doubled back and listened but i was too
young for that
people don't even realize that mace had
like an entire
you know murder mates was a real thing
yo it was so crazy when mace came back
as
like with the jesus [ __ ] and then he
went back to the gangster [ __ ] with
g-unit for like one mixtape
i was so confused i was like what but
honestly i'm at the same time i might
have been confused
but i was i was hyped though i'm like
okay
murder back on murder time okay yeah
that didn't work out though
and then he went back to the
the welcome back album with the brewers
hat on
and then yeah i actually got to meet
mace very nice guys well
you uh have you have you ever worked
with mace nah
nah yeah you gotta bring murder mace
back for reverse man
i would love to do it soon with mace
mace is a legend man of course man
[ __ ] one of the biggest to do it from
holland oh for sure i
i would argue peak if we're measuring
peak
the biggest yeah i mean he's the only
artist i know that went triple p i'm
talking
i'm not talking about total run or
influence on the culture but i'm talking
about like
commercial success peak-wise for like a
year maybe what about with cam and mace
it's it's one of those two commercials
macy's [ __ ] who you think had a was
bigger
oh mace you think so oh yeah
why do you think that bro that's like
that [ __ ]
because he has songs with mariah cause
can't make something right no i think
it's
i think it's like heart like bro that
that like 12 month [ __ ]
run mace was like the guy well he
brought
cam in no for sure no you're right yeah
confessions of fire i remember like [ __ ]
i [ __ ] with that originally because
mace was on it mm-hmm
what was the song on that album where he
was talking about [ __ ] his aunt or
his mom or some crazy [ __ ] there was
some wild [ __ ]
the song was actually called confessions
of fire nah you bugging he ain't say
that though he ain't say the mama
to that to the song that's what i'm
telling you but he ain't saying there
was some
loud [ __ ] he said on there about oh yeah
yeah he might have said he said no he
said see what that dust does
he said i might he was saying a bunch of
off the wall [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] and i was
like this guy's crazy
i don't know if it was not i don't think
he said the mom would love it but it was
it was some [ __ ] that was like off the
wall like that though where i was like
oh this guy
camera is different i asked him i said
yo i see your fleet why you um switched
to style
said nah you know [ __ ] be trying to
take my [ __ ] man
see eminem rain with the whole [ __ ] out
let them have it
but he was doing it before he was doing
that dark [ __ ] on confessions of like
for hi kids you want you like violence
yeah
because i remember thinking like there
was the horse and carriage record and
then i
bought the album and i was like oh no
this is some
there's some other this [ __ ] is dark
he's
yeah yeah look him up erica you know
what was dope too
uh uh to join with him at odb
that was classic oh yeah